[Musique]
c'est une photo de la judokate française
Margot Pineau le visage tuméfié qui
depuis 24 heures sur les réseaux sociaux
tous les deux se sont battus en les gens
de la
petite amie
de violence conjugale
frapper au sol à plusieurs reprises et
finalement étrangler
alors grande question à les réseaux
sociaux sont-ils devenus plus utile que
le commissariat là elle a posté une
photo je voulais la revoir cette photo
qui est assez A35 est vraiment la photo
qui a fait réagir tout le monde elle
explique donc sous cette photo ne pas
comprendre pourquoi son compagnon à la
suite quel accusé de violence a été
relaxé elle nous raconte dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche j'ai été victime d'une
agression à mon domicile par mon
compagnon est l'entraîneur j'ai été
insultée rouer de coups de poing ma tête
a été frappé au sol à plusieurs reprises
et finalement étrangler j'ai cru mourir
que faut que voleur défense calomnieuse
pas ça mais balai sur est le sens on
sent le solde de mon appartement que
manque est-il la mort au bout peut-être
c'est probablement le judo qui m'a sauvé
est-ce que vous comprenez oui
de toute façon on ne touche pas une
femme on ne va pas une femme de toute
façon quoi qu'il arrive et toujours je
rappelle après
reviens dans combien de temps on ne fera
pas une femme quoi qu'il arrive à
s'engueuler
[Musique]
excusez-moi il y a une plainte suivi son
coup il a été jugé en comparution
immédiate parce que tu paraissais établi
et il a été relaxé donc c'est pas un
défaut d'enquête elle repart café
appelle
problème c'est la justice qui n'a pas
été capable de
il a réussi à obtenir
tous les deux
Bonjour me porter plainte dans un
commissariat il n'y a pas de jugement
immédiat
parce que la violence
quand on le touche pas on ne touche pas
une femme on ne se bat pas on ne règle
pas on ne règle pas les problèmes de
couple avec des regarder les deux parce
que moi je ne connais pas
et
qu'il ne serai jamais une femme on
regarde un extrait
moi qui qui connaissent ma personnalité
c'est très bien que je peux pas te
frapper une femme ceux qui me
connaissent j'ai jamais frappé une femme
de ma vie et ça n'arrivera jamais
a donné il a donné également sa sa
version des faits je vous propose de
l'écouter et on en débat ensuite
je suis dans je suis dans la porte ma
tête elle conne
elle se cogne on se cogne je tombe
dessus elle me fait tomber sur elle on
se retrouve à terre ça continue elle me
sert elle me parle
j'essaie de partir elle saute saute sur
la planche pas quoi les mains on les a
quoi on les a posé donc il y a pas de
cou qui arrive directement au visage ou
mon attention c'est quand même de me de
me diriger vers la porte quoi donc
voilà et après on a tout le temps enfin
c'était c'était horrible on peut se dire
aussi que parce qu'elle contester cette
décision de justice et le parquet fait
appel en le rappel il a convoqué lui
cette conférence de presse donc c'est ça
fait émerger quand même des choses
est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est que
c'est bien qu'il fasse des conférences
de presse quel est saisi les les les
réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Géraldine moi je suis très
embarrassé mais je suis très choquée et
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à prendre parti
parce que effectivement je l'écoute et
je la crois et j'écoute après son
compagnon et je le crois et en fait je
ne peux pas à moi me mettre dans leur
chambre à coucher évidemment je avant
qu'il fasse la conférence de presse nuit
elle a eu le beaucoup de soutien est
belle Teddy Riner de la Fédération parce
que j'estime en est et c'est hyper
important il faut le dire globalement
c'est plus ces femmes qui sont les
hommes que les femmes se plaignent où
déposer des des plein dans les
commissariats et ben 98 % ce sont des
vrais plante donc bien sûr il faut le
redire il faut libérer la parole mais
nous on assiste on est dans une chambre
à coucher comme ça et on assiste à une
sœur de scène de baston entre un homme
et une femme avec vraiment le choc des
images c'est vraiment très très violent
et je trouve que on peut pas et est-ce
que cela je veux pas que les réseaux
sociaux je pense qu'il faut vraiment que
toujours toujours commissariat justice
commissariat de La Fayette du système
alors il y en a certains qui dit sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux façon c'est un
c'est un
choc déséquilibré parce que de toute
façon l'homme est plus fort que la femme
et par ailleurs lui il apparaîtra
toujours comme un beau parce que c'était
rien
s'il avait vraiment te porter les coups
qu'elle dit il l'aurait peut-être aussi
des 2 côtés
pour
la tension
on me demande de prendre parti dans une
affaire sur laquelle je n'ai pas tous
les éléments effectivement j'étais avec
elle tout en étant un peu choqué que ça
soit est allé dans les médias tout de
suite et après je l'entends lui je me
dis merde est-ce qu'on a pas été injuste
donc moi je déteste qu'on me prenne à
partir et qu'on me demande même en même
temps est-ce que je pose la question
mais est-ce que si le parquet fait appel
de la décision ça veut dire que
peut-être la plaignante
elle a bien fait de prendre la parole
parce que ça va peut-être faire voir si
elle a eu 10 jours d'été et elle dénonce
une tentative d'étranglement quand même
donc ça va très très loin après vous
savez souvent dit la justice va trop
lentement la justice aller trop vite et
comme il comparution immédiate sinon je
voulais te dire
arrête pas de dire que pour les femmes
battues c'est trop long immédiatement
réagir que la justice que la prise de la
plante elle est jamais fait à temps et
que par ailleurs on laisse traîner et
que parfois ça conduit à des féministes
mais
du coup il n'est pas alors peut-être
c'est ça le problème
est que pour elle il n'était pas dans
son état normal
il était convenu en tout cas quand je
rentre je suis rentré sur la route
qu'on se retrouverait à chez moi du coup
avec Alain
pour que j'emmène le lendemain à
l'aéroport pour qu'il parte en Israël
il arrivait beaucoup plus tard à 2h du
matin
alcoolisé je lui ai fait la remarque
aussi qu'il était tard que je l'avais
attendu quand même 2h
je suis donc allé me coucher
il m'a rejoint et elle elle donne sa
version des faits en racontant
l'agression elle a des mots très très
fort elle a dit elle a eu peur du pire
il a fait un geste je l'ai repoussé et
là ça a commencé il a pris mes cheveux
il m'a pris par les cheveux et ma tirer
vers le sol à côté à gauche du lit et il
a commencé à mettre des coups de poing
droit de demain en tout cas il a
commencé à prendre ma tête de mes
cheveux à me cogner la tête sur le sol
il a voulu m'étrangler et voilà j'ai
j'ai cru que j'allais laisser ma vie et
comme j'ai dit
son esprit de de guerrière de combattant
de qui m'a sauvé c'est le judo s'est
fait que je puisse t'être résister à tes
coup parce que ils ont été nombreux et
jamais j'ai fait ça fasse une violence
comme ça alors
que
moi je suis désolé
effectivement
si jamais il fera pas une femme de
l'autre côté il déconne qui sont battus
tous les deux donc c'est
quand on se bat un homme
il arrive même si votre femme devient je
ne sais pas après un coup de sang et se
jette sur vous vous vous vous la bloquer
vous êtes partis répondez pas
récemment des des des des filles ou des
ce soir il faut laisser la justice et
vous nous avez dit oui